sono puliamo gabriele gianluigi enrico è
insieme siamo quattro fratelli mi ha
chiesto su instagram di farci fare la
prima intervista quadro di mandarci
delle domande le ho raccolte e arrivato
il momento di rispondere c'è la frontera
ganz e pronti notte gianni vai con le
domande come ha fatto vostra madre
gestibili ma nello sarà di mente si
rimorchia di più enrico dire carriera
briede gian germano chi pensa che
fidanzato da condannato secondo me
guglielmo antica il più bravo a gestire
i conflitti con gli ex moglie secondo me
pure guglielmo ii che si sono più però
gestire i conflitti ma non per merito
mio
per demerito loro segni zodiacali
sagittario toro ariete toro tanti ci
sederemo nel nostro segno ma che il 50
per cento di qua dentro il buon 50 per
cento si conoscono il potere dei segni
di fuoco lo pensate di cattoliche
senologica insegnanti piace moltissimo è
uno dei preferiti siete sempre d'accordo
per un periodo di sete odiati odiati
domenech non siamo andati d'accordo però
abbiamo litigato tipo il gabriele
gabriele jean louis uccisi e gabriele
mi sarebbe piaciuto avere una sorella ma
non ci ho mai pensato io non ci ho mai
pensato e pensandoci effettivamente no
io mi dirà in realtà se ragionarci no
qual è il vostro fratello preferito e
dico il mio fratello dell'editore errigo
descrizione o fratelli preferiti a parte
il regio avesse preferito essere figli
unici ci si porta media da questa sedia
e guarda in basso
[Risate]
come ha influito la separazione dei
vostri genitori su di voi che rapporto
avete con vostro padre alla separazione
sicuramente influito nel bene e nel male
nella persona che sono oggi quindi anche
il material testo positivo perché non
vorrei essere altro e con mio papà
devo dire che inizialmente ho avuto
maggiori problemi infatti non ne ho mai
parlato tantissimo le video crescendo
poi maturando questi problemi sono
andati un pochino a scemare a volte ti
rendi conto degli errori non vengono
sono una parte che data anche tu a
cazzate io invece ho un partner esatti
sono cresciuto senza palle nel senso che
si sono ricorse harvey e rovi minuscolo
quindi è normale e altobello di un'unica
sbattere sto dicendo una cosa seria dice
quindi non so cosa significhi crescere
con due genitori in realtà con i ragazzi
non sembra dei mancati rischio ha detto
tutto per averlo crescendo comunque ti
rendi molto dei limiti delle persone
magari significheranno tuoi ritorna per
la vecchia e quindi comunque sia invece
di odiare cominci a capire quindi ad
essere più morbido e con un costituto da
piccolo vedi il padre genitore quando
sei più grande e inizia a vedere la
persona no quindi inizia a vedere più
umanamente come persone e non come il
genitore a chi di voi già sapeva o
sospettava che fosse gay
e chi è stato il più sorpreso al co ming
out al coming
ma jean king roger inglese posso parlare
mi fate parlare noti veloce io non sono
assolutamente certo che non ci ho mai
pensato effettivamente 15 ragazzi però
che più ha vent'anni è andato a fare
vivi e fatto non temete però è molto
poco presente a se stesso chi lo sapeva
già
gabriele ma ne ho già raccontato alla
stampa che a nessuno piace il commento
del colore calato il mio telefono a
gabriele quando una comprendono nuovo
colpo sono comparsi tutti i miei
messaggi che avevo cancellato e a
percepire rispettiamo il mio fratello
era sopra è sbagliato tutto la lettura
diciamolo a letto tutto possiamo pero
capire un bar di casisa fa male ma
perché ci servì a telefonare a progetti
per continuare il fisico da com.it.es
abbiamo già il nome ma non si vuol dire
abbiamo già il nome facciamo una cosa
piccola perché noi non entriamo entriamo
poco il più intelligente guglielmo
enrico e rino dipende dalla ed il nome
amore apr ok non so più intelligente
ovvero e guillermo il più rompipalle
lasogga bene il più affascinante
gianluigi secondo gabrielli più fascino
magnetico beach annuncio è quello che
non ha bisogno
fa piacere che deciderà di farlo è stata
il più simpatico gabriella gabrielli
enrico giornata della serie a che a
parate simpaticissimo semmai una
mattonata noi anche gianluigi simpatica
realtà non è per l'esordio in più
stronzo iracà stronzi nessuno eh sì
perché stronza e doppiato cercava aiuto
scythe cangini n nessuno da si può dire
nessuno forse io a volte allora boxing
stronzo perché non ti risponde mai è
stronzo per verdi bandi guardia su di me
il ricordo più bello d infanzia per
attanagliando l'infanzia rischio è che
una volta stavamo a tagliacozzo glielo
proprio minuscolo c'era muretto con una
siepe e dietro cenno al fossato con
baciavi è basata stato due metri la pro
avuto 5 anni e mi ricordo di saltarlo
sta assieme senza vedere quello che
c'era dietro e io prendevo
lanciamo poi ovviamente più antiche
facciate invece minuscolo incominciata
remare verso l'isola minore ragazzi a
una boa di quelli che segnano le navi
tipo piena zeppa di ricci ci siamo
avvicinati al tanto dall'aver e il
rumore bucato in mezzo al mare in tutto
questo non sovrapporsi un genitore in
volta non siamo riusciti a generare
tratta rainato una barca sarà della
domanda piccante
abbiamo perso prima la verginità
juventino c'erano 15 anni io xvi ea chi
come braglia assomigliate a due a due
però la somiglianza o la moto è già
legge nella nota è neanche io manco io
un po di nomi di giocarne harry ma tra
che neanche io vedo mai arrivo metti la
prima qualche parte quanto siete atti
180 metri e 70 reale l 69 di l'oreal e
perché la gente c'è sempre a rubina
dell'altezza lasciavano attore alcune 75
con i tacchi sono lo volevo contro
figurone sondato la maria l'acqua
infatti sarò 175 falso che questo non un
82 falso
vero perché tutti il mio era senza
scarpe ea tutti i 90 che io ho beccato
mentre io comunque penso di essere 182
reale però così non voglio paragonare a
guglielmo che un 89 si sono creati due
lo conferma teme treno confermate ma
anche io invece sono 187 reale sono 170
reale però quindi mi chiedo che avviene
doveva già essere un esteta sono più
antica pietà
no io sono misurato dal medico con la
presta quella che faccio lascia due
centimetri invece la chi è il vostro
cugino preferito in assoluto e perché
proprio la linea io non ho cugini
preferiti ma devo dire che crescendo mi
sono molto legato con la linea e in a
perchè io sono qui oppure non o fuggire
i preferiti
però ovviamente ci sono quelli più
vicini alla mia età con cui ho condiviso
di più quelli più piccoli poi crescendo
loro abbiamo creato un rapporto per
andare in sé creare un rapporto con la
linea che il completamente diverso come
diceva di avere la stessa e dalle stesse
cose avviene campana vigna io crescendo
ho riscontrato molto una figura che è
latina ragazzi che è pazzesca cioè punto
di riferimento proprio staff rapito
spingano in un video di tutto ti gira
lunga fossi sì sì sì voglio bene laghi
la cosa più schifosa che hai visto fare
ai tuoi fratelli ce la fa ce ne sono
gianluigi negli in corea casa come terna
mangiavano come il tyrannosaurus rex
quindi stavano con le mani che non le
poteva osare mettere in piede sopra la
bresaola e non raggiungevano una preda
che avevano bloccato perché in barattolo
dell'es correggere se sì comunque ci
sono sempre di una cosa è una cosa
meravigliosa quel barattolo ad oggi sarà
ancora diversa da quella del tiro della
mente storico ho fatto la cacca mare e
poi l'ho presa e l'ho tirata contro jam
altro enrico e loro poi vedendo colpiti
dalla mia me l'hanno ripresa e la
ritirata cioè mammario chiariamo vi
capita mai di essere gelosi l'uno
dell'altro no no no a posto cosa si
intende per geloso perché in allarme due
volte
[Applauso]
perché dico è l'unico senza g come prima
lettera nonno che si chiama gino nostro
padre giuseppe
cioè non ci hanno certo sono finiti lega
quanti nomi che esistono con la cibo che
starebbero bene dico a dire che con
scilla non sanno ben molti nomi già
conosci la bambino giaconi scrivete nei
commenti tutti in biologia e quello con
più like sarà comunque nelle lo
chiameremo da oggi in poi semmai era
vera private ma benissimo epicoco meno
per chi di voi ai bicipiti più grandi
giocatori ci facciamo li vede anche un
po più a favore
quali sono i c'è stata a 3mila tende
teli com'era mondo da piccolo picconando
malato era quando una scarpa e la prima
così era malato tutto mirko dermatiti
tocsins su precise maggiore salama lega
sta malissimo è stato salvato al bello
pienotto sta fuori
avete mai invidiato la bellezza di
guglielmo chi sei e restiamo in risposta
e vuole sentirsi di vi siete mai chiesti
come sarebbe vivere per un giorno la
vita dell'altro si preservi limbo che
capaci di divertire institute break
arriva aleggianti già di via con
francesca no o sì terribile gravità che
fu il video è quella di enrico nole pia
quindi vengono da terribili tra
campionato hubble e noiosissima perché
mi hanno veramente un basso chi è il più
permaloso enrico siamo tutti per mano
sinora simboleggiate un po così sino a
sinistra la risposta è il sale a capire
in questo video
ringrazio gabriele già grigi enrico che
assomiglio dicendo una parola
ma non possiamo sapere dove andare a
parare
non lo so per chiudere il video dei
ragazzi a meno gravi difficoltà ragazzi
grazie al gatto ragazzi grazie a voi per
il vostro tempo che vi invitiamo da
invitato a mettere like e iscrivervi e
un pollice
alla prossima ciao ciao sono vogliamo
gabriele gianluigi enrico no per i
gelati